Bene, buonasera di nuovo. Allora, questa sera io mi ero impegnato a parlarvi, mi sono impegnato a parlarvi
di un mercante del Medioevo, a cercare di capire come pensava e come vedeva il mondo un mercante del Medioevo.
Questo mercante è Dino Compagni, che è un mercante fiorentino vissuto fra 200 e 300, più o meno contemporaneo di Dante
e che ci ha scritto un piccolo libro, chi c'era ieri sera ricorda che Fra Salimbene ha scritto una cronaca di 900 pagine.
Dino Compagni ha scritto un piccolo libro, molto più maneggevole, in cui ha voluto raccontare certe cose importanti
che sono successe a Firenze quando lui non solo abitava lì, ma era anche un uomo che contava a Firenze, Dino.
E in questo senso mi sono detto che forse a pensarci meglio, anziché dirvi come pensava, come vedeva il mondo,
un mercante del Medioevo, avrei forse fatto meglio a dire come vedeva il mondo un politico del Medioevo,
perché in realtà Dino è innanzitutto un uomo di politica. Il Dino che si racconta in questa cronaca
è innanzitutto uno che ha fatto politica a Firenze e che ci racconta cosa voleva dire fare politica
nella Firenze dei comuni, nella Firenze dei Guelfi e degli Ibellini, dei Bianchi e dei Neri.
Non era uno scherzo fare politica in quel mondo, ben inteso.
Dino naturalmente è un mercante, è un imprenditore, è un imprenditore che appartiene alla corporazione di Por Santa Maria,
che ha questo nome un po' curioso, è una corporazione fiorentina che si occupa di grande commercio,
che si occupa di import-export di panni. Dino ha una sua ditta importante, è un uomo ricco,
però è un uomo che per una certa fase della sua vita fa politica, si trova al governo della città.
Poi le cose gli vanno male, la sua parte viene sconfitta, viene buttato fuori dalla politica,
continua a vivere a Firenze, continua a fare il suo mestiere di imprenditore,
e però ha dentro questa cosa che lo rode, che lui per un po' di tempo è stato al potere,
ha cercato, dice lui, di evitare che le cose andassero così male come stanno andando.
E adesso che vede che le cose vanno veramente male,
e lui rimpiange un po' gli anni in cui è stato seduto su quelle poltrone,
e aveva la possibilità di incidere, insomma, e dice almeno mi è venuta voglia di scrivere,
di scrivere per raccontare, se non altro, quello che ho visto,
che non sono cose edificanti per niente, dice.
Mi è venuta voglia di scrivere, per un po' di tempo ho tenuto duro,
perché dicevo tanto non sono capace, è un mercante, non sa il latino.
Non è come Fra Salimbene che abbiamo conosciuto ieri sera,
che il latino lo sa perfettamente, pensa in latino, è in grado di scrivere.
No, no, Dino scrive in italiano, sa leggere e scrivere, come sa far di conto,
perché è un uomo di commercio, è un uomo d'azienda, deve saper tenere i conti.
Ma il latino non lo sa, o lo sa poco, lui scrive in italiano, in toscano.
Dice pensavo di non essere capace.
Poi soprattutto dice, ho lasciato perdere per un bel po'
credendo che altri scrivesse.
E questa è una cosa che, secondo me, è significativa, a me ha colpito.
Voi capite, siamo in un mondo dove non ci sono i giornali, la televisione, non c'è niente.
Succedono grandi avvenimenti, la politica ha i suoi conflitti anche violentissimi,
ci sono grandi cambiamenti nel potere, nel governo, avvengono queste grandi cose
e in futuro cosa ne sapranno?
E in futuro ne sapranno qualcosa se qualcuno scrive,
perché se non c'è qualcuno che scrive, si perderà la memoria di tutto questo.
E Dino dice, io credendo che altri scrivesse, per molto tempo ho lasciato perdere.
Poi gli è venuta voglia di scrivere lui, di dire la sua.
E quindi dice la sua.
Però, appunto, la sua è la voce di un uomo che è stato in politica,
che è stato influente,
che poi a un certo punto ha perso,
è stato buttato fuori
e quindi noi ovviamente ci dobbiamo fare la tara sui giudizi di valore.
Però a noi non interessa qui decidere se era meglio i Guelfi o i Ghibellini,
meglio i Bianchi o meglio i Neri.
Qui, come dire, la scommessa è provare a capire come vedeva il mondo Dino Compagni,
mercante della corporazione di Port Santa Maria al tempo di Dante.
E allora?
E allora cominciamo a raccontare come mai un mercante come Dino Compagni,
un imprenditore, si trova a un certo punto al governo della città.
Non è una cosa così ovvia,
perché
non voglio richiamarmi sempre a quello che ho detto ieri,
perché magari tanta gente che c'è qua giustamente ieri non c'era,
però ieri abbiamo parlato di un frate francescano
che però era di nobile famiglia,
apparteneva a una grande famiglia di cavalieri di Parma.
Ecco, nei comuni italiani
c'era una nobiltà di grandi famiglie,
nobili,
gente che aveva degli antenati, uno stemma,
delle terre, dei castelli,
delle torri in città,
dei cavalli, delle armi,
l'abitudine a combattere,
l'abitudine a partecipare ai tornei,
questi gentiluomini, come li chiamavano loro,
per tanto tempo erano stati quelli che avevano comandato nelle città.
Comandavano loro,
i mercanti stavano a bottega,
stavano al fondaco,
gli artigiani stavano a lavorare,
nei comuni, comandavano i nobili,
comandavano i cavalieri.
E l'ammirazione per i nobili,
per i cavalieri,
per questa gente che appartiene
a un mondo superiore,
socialmente dico,
fa ancora parte della visione del mondo di Dino Compagni.
Dino Compagni, che è un mercante,
non è uno di loro.
E anzi, con loro,
lo vedremo,
non avrebbe neanche nessun interesse in comune,
anzi, con i nobili,
lui, quando è in politica,
ha in realtà degli scontri durissimi,
però,
per un uomo di quell'epoca,
i gentiluomini,
i cavalieri,
sono ancora qualche cosa,
insomma, di fronte a cui istintivamente
uno si leva il cappello davanti ai cavalieri.
Voi pensate che a Firenze
ci sono una serie di abitudini.
Dino le racconta.
Una volta era un funerale,
si seppelliva una donna dei frescobaldi,
c'era un sacco di gente in piazza,
e come si usa da noi a Firenze,
tutti i cittadini sedevano a terra
su stuoie,
nel Medioevo avevano pochi mobili,
e si sedevano a terra con una facilità,
una disinvoltura,
con cui oggi noi non lo faremmo più.
Dice Dino,
come si usa da noi a Firenze,
al funerale,
tutti i cittadini erano seduti per terra,
su stuoie,
tranne i cavalieri
e i dottori.
Quelli erano seduti su panche,
più in alto.
I dottori sono i laureati dell'università,
vabbè non mi soffermerò sul fatto
che il prestigio dei professori universitari
una volta,
vabbè comunque,
una volta è la maggiorità,
comunque,
in ogni caso,
i cavalieri e i dottori,
i laureati in legge,
i giudici,
ecco,
quelli stavano sulle panche,
gli altri sotto.
E non è soltanto una questione di onore,
e i cavalieri sono i cittadini
che contano di più
da tutti i punti di vista.
A un certo punto,
a Firenze,
hanno esiliato
un certo numero di cittadini
per ragioni politiche.
Poi si pentono,
si accorgono che si sono sbagliati,
li fanno tornare
e gli danno un risarcimento,
dice Dino,
ma di più ai cavalieri
cavalieri
e di meno agli altri.
Perché essere cavalieri
significa comunque
far parte,
essere l'elite della società.
I cavalieri,
voi capite,
sono necessari,
mandi un'ambasciata al Papa.
Chi ci mandi?
Un ciabattino?
Il ciabattino può anche stare al governo,
come vedremo a Firenze,
ma nell'ambasciata al Papa
ci devi mettere dei cavalieri,
della gente che è abituata
a stare in società,
a frequentare i potenti,
che è beneducata,
e poi i cavalieri
sono necessari in guerra.
Perché è vero
che il Comune
quando fa la guerra
chiama tutti a combattere
e quindi tutti i cittadini,
gli artigiani,
i mercanti,
tutti organizzati
in compagnie di quartiere,
tutti a piedi
con le loro lanci,
i loro scudi,
sì,
però i nobili
che sanno stare a cavallo,
che hanno le armature,
che passano la vita
a combattere nei tornei,
i nobili cavalieri
senza di loro
non si fa un esercito,
sono loro quelli
che vincono le battaglie,
non la massa
dei plebei,
dei borghesi
inquadrati
nelle loro compagnie
di fanti.
Quindi i nobili
sono fondamentali
per la vita del Comune
e per tanto tempo
hanno comandato loro.
E i nobili,
mi accorgo
che io vi devo parlare
di come vedeva
il mondo
Dino Compagni
e invece vi sto parlando
degli altri,
di quelli che erano diversi
da lui,
di quelli che lui guardava
dal basso
e che si trovava
sulla testa.
un mercante
di allora
viveva in una città italiana
e sulla sua testa
c'erano i signori,
c'erano i nobili.
Non importa
se il Comune
è democratico
e tutti votano,
i nobili
contano.
I nobili
condividono
un sistema di valori,
l'ideologia cavalleresca
dove
insomma
uno deve
sapersi sacrificare,
deve sapersi
far ammazzare
in battaglia
se ce n'è bisogno,
dove l'onore
è al centro
di tutto.
Dino Compagni
a un certo punto
racconta una grande battaglia
anzi
è il punto di partenza
della sua cronaca
una grande battaglia
in cui i fiorentini
hanno sconfitto Arezzo
la battaglia di Campaldino
dove ha combattuto
anche Dante
che era un nobile
tra i cavalieri
di Firenze
e Dino dice
quella battaglia
è stata durissima
c'è della gente
che si è fatta ammazzare
piuttosto che arretrare
c'è anche chi è scappato
mentre si pensava
che dovesse fare chissà cosa
poi invece è scappato
ma molti
si sono battuti
molto bene
e dice Dino
quel mattino
prima della battaglia
si erano armati
dei nuovi cavalieri
cioè un certo numero
di giovani nobili
erano stati addobbati
cavalieri
con il rituale
che trasforma
di un uomo
qualunque
in un cavaliere
la spada posata
sulla spalla
ecco
ed è ovvio
che un giovane
che è stato armato
cavaliere quel mattino
se poi c'è la battaglia
al pomeriggio
si fa ammazzare
piuttosto che far
brutta figura
quindi i valori
dei cavalieri
sono centrali
in questa società
e per tanto tempo
i mercanti
come Dino
se ne sono stati
al negozio
al fondaco
all'impresa
a scambiare denaro
a scambiare merci
a comprare tessuti
a fare l'import export
sapendo che questo
loro lavoro
fruttava tanti soldi
sì
però rispetto
alla vita
dei cavalieri
che vanno in giro
a cavallo
che hanno le proprietà
terriere
che non lavorano
ecco
rispetto a loro
un mercante
insomma
è sempre un po'
un poveraccio
nella prospettiva
ancora di quella generazione
dunque
per tanto tempo
i nobili cavalieri
hanno comandato
a Firenze
come in tutte le città italiane
e i mercanti
come Dino
sotto
a ubbidire
e a lavorare
e a fare i soldi
e a pagare le tasse
però i nobili
sono anche ingombranti
è pesante
una città
gestita
da questo tipo
di gente
questa è gente
che va in giro armata
che ha sempre
la spada
al fianco
in qualunque momento
e che la tira fuori
se c'è qualcosa
che gli dà fastidio
i nobili
pensano solo
alla guerra
sanno farla
sanno combattere
e hanno la tendenza
spiacevole
a tirar fuori la spada
anche in situazioni
dove magari
i due mercanti
si metterebbero a discutere
e provare a mettersi d'accordo
i nobili no
i nobili occupano
i posti importanti
non solo
nel comune
nella vita politica
ma anche nella chiesa
i vescovi
sono tutti nobili
poi magari
sono come
quel vescovo di Arezzo
di cui racconta
Dino Compagni
Guglielmino
degli Ubertini
il quale
dice Dino Compagni
il vescovo di Arezzo
sapea meglio
gli uffici
della guerra
della chiesa
e in effetti
in guerra
si farà ammazzare
alla testa
della cavalleria di Arezzo
alla battaglia di Campaldino
questi sono i nobili
i nobili
sono organizzati
in famiglie
Dino Compagni
quando descrive
la società
vede innanzitutto
al vertice
quello che lui chiama
le famiglie
se vi evoca
un panorama
un po' mafioso
non vi sbagliate
perché siamo lì
i nobili
sono le famiglie
perché i nobili
hanno tanti parenti
un cognome importante
spesso solo i nobili
hanno il cognome
Dino Compagni
ha un cognome
perché è già un borghese ricco
ma la maggior parte
dei fiorentini
non ha neanche un cognome
si chiamano
Dino di Giovanni
di Andrea
di Bartolomeo
invece i nobili
sono i cavalcanti
i brunelleschi
i tozinghi
e così via
i nobili
sono le famiglie
e ogni famiglia
è numerosa
dice a un certo punto
i cavalcanti
c'è stato un litigio
tra diverse famiglie
contro i cavalcanti
e i cavalcanti
erano forti
solo loro
erano 60 uomini
capaci di portare
le armi
voi capite
che se uno deve andare
in piazza
si sta facendo politica
dobbiamo andare in piazza
e solo della nostra famiglia
siamo in 60
che vanno in piazza
a cavallo
con l'armatura
e beh
quello pesa
e queste famiglie
queste famiglie
sono pronte
ad ammazzare
per difendere
il loro potere
il loro onore
per difendere
i loro interessi
queste famiglie
sono delle consorterie
di potere
dove non è che ci si vuole bene
ma gli interessi
sono quelli
che tengono insieme tutto
c'è un passo straordinario
in Dino
sta raccontando
una cosa
che è successa
ad Arezzo
c'era appunto
quel tal vescovo
che vi dicevo prima
il vescovo di Arezzo
che si intendeva
più di guerra
che di chiesa
il quale
dice Dino
a un certo punto
c'è stato un problema politico
il vescovo ha tradito
la sua parte
ha tradito la sua famiglia
ha cercato di accordarsi
con i fiorentini
mentre i suoi amici
e parenti
volevano fare la guerra
contro Firenze
allora dice Dino
ad Arezzo
si sono un po' seccati
per il fatto
che il vescovo
stava negoziando
col nemico
e quindi
dice Dino
come se fosse
la cosa più normale
del mondo
decisero di farlo uccidere
dunque il governo
di Arezzo
riunito
dice qui
il vescovo ci sta dando fastidio
quindi lo facciamo ammazzare
nel consiglio
di Arezzo
c'è anche
un parente
del vescovo
Messer Guglielmo
De Pazzi
suo consorto
consorte
cioè membro
della stessa consorteria
familiare del vescovo
quando sente
questa cosa
che si discute
di farlo ammazzare
il vescovo
Messer Guglielmo
De Pazzi
che era nel consiglio
disse
che sarebbe stato
molto contento
se l'avessero fatto
non l'avendo saputo
ma essendo richiesto
non consentirebbe
cioè
in altre parole
se lo facevate
senza dirmelo
a me andava benissimo
perché sono d'accordo
anch'io
che questo vescovo
è veramente
asseccato
ecco
però è un mio parente
quindi non potete chiedermi
che io voti
per farlo ammazzare
in consiglio comunale
mi dispiace
ma io non posso votare
per farlo ammazzare
ecco
questo è il modo
in cui i nobili
fanno politica
i nobili fanno politica
e hanno sempre
la spada al fianco
e sono pronti
a tirarla fuori
e la gente
come Dino
non ha la spada
al fianco
i mercanti
lavorano
fanno soldi
non hanno la spada
non vanno in giro
a cavallo
e non hanno neanche
tanti parenti
quanti ne hanno
i nobili
Dino compagno
in tutta la cronaca
non parla mai
di un suo parente
per i nobili
la famiglia è tutto
i parenti vengono fuori
continuamente
tutto
gira intorno
alla parentela
Dino non ne ha
di parenti
è un uomo
che si è fatto da solo
ecco è un self made man
veramente
come tanti di questi
popolani di Firenze
i nobili
hanno gestito Firenze
per tanto tempo
ma non l'hanno gestita
pacificamente
perché fra loro
si scannano
fra loro si scannano
per interesse
si creano raggruppamenti
di famiglie
a un certo punto
sono nati
lo sapete tutti
i guelfi
e i ghibellini
quelli che vorrebbero
che il mondo
fosse comandato
dal papa
e quelli che vorrebbero
che il mondo
fosse comandato
dall'imperatore
ma in realtà
uno diventa guelfo
perché la famiglia
nobile rivale
sta con i ghibellini
e quelli ci hanno fatto
uno sgarbo
tanti anni fa
non ci si ricorda
quale sgarbo
ci ricordiamo neanche più
veramente
però si sa
che con quelli
siamo nemici
e se loro
sono ghibellini
noi siamo guelfi
a Dino compagni
di tutto questo
non importa niente
lui è un uomo
d'affari
che pensa a fare i soldi
a importare i panni
dalla Francia
però sa
che nella sua città
per tanto tempo
hanno dominato
queste fazioni
di grande famiglie nobili
le maladette parti
perché è proprio
questa divisione
della città
in partiti
che per la gente
come Dino
è il punto di partenza
di tutti i mali
se fossimo tutti uniti
ne riparleremo
invece non siamo tutti uniti
queste clientele
che si costruiscono
intorno alle grandi famiglie
sono forti
sono radicate
non sono solo i nobili
hanno i loro seguaci
una grande famiglia nobile
possiede tante case in città
le dà in affitto
possiede botteghe
se tu sei un affittuario
degli uberti
stai con loro
se sei uno
come dire
un imprenditore
che lavora per gli uberti
stai con loro
comunque
gli uberti
lo sapete
sono la grande famiglia
ghibellina
che a un certo punto
viene cacciata da Firenze
quando vincono i Guelfi
e non torneranno mai più
tutti ricordano
Farinata degli uberti
nell'inferno di Dante
ecco
Dino racconta
che a un certo punto
c'è una tregua
c'è un momento
di tregua
in cui si fa una cosa
che non si era mai vista
si mettono d'accordo
e lasciano rientrare
i ghibellini
esiliati
a Firenze
durerà pochissimo
dopo pochi mesi
litigano
li ributtano fuori
ma in quel momento
che i ghibellini
esiliati
sono tornati a Firenze
e per la prima volta
sono tornati
gli uberti
a Firenze
e si sono visti
gli uberti
entrare a Firenze
a cavallo
con i loro scudi
con il loro stemma
dice Dino
si vedeva
tanta gente
vecchi ghibellini
uomini e donne
che correvano
a baciare
lo stemma
degli uberti
dopo 50 anni
che gli uberti
erano esiliati
dalla città
quindi queste parti
sono radicate
sono profondamente
radicate
questo è un mondo
fazioso
faziosissimo
dove
a differenza
della nostra
faziosità politica
di oggi
loro hanno
uno sfogo maggiore
quando proprio
non ne puoi più
gli altri li ammazzi
ecco
di fronte
a questa situazione
la gente
come Dino
a un certo punto
non ne può più
la gente come Dino
che vorrebbe lavorare
fare i soldi
in una città pacifica
a un certo punto
decide che i nobili
sono la maledizione
di questa città
se non ci fossero i nobili
si starebbe tanto bene
tutti a lavorare
niente guelfi
niente ghibellini
e allora nasce
quello che loro chiamano
il governo
di popolo
popolo è una parola
grossa
popolo vorrebbe dire
tutti tranne i nobili
in realtà a Firenze
popolo vuol dire
come dire
la brava gente
che paga le tasse
quindi innanzitutto
gli imprenditori
quelli che hanno bottega
che hanno un'impresa
quello è il popolo
a Firenze
fanno a un certo punto
un governo di popolo
che sarebbe
come dire oggi
un governo
della confindustria
sostanzialmente
al vertice
del comune
mettono una giunta
di sei priori
e questi sei priori
sono nominati
dalle corporazioni
le corporazioni
sono le organizzazioni
appunto confindustriali
sostanzialmente
loro ne hanno tante
i pellicciai
gli imprenditori
della seta
quelli della lana
i notai
i medici
ecco
il governo
è in mano a questi
ed è in questa fase
che un uomo come Dino
si trova al governo
perché finché
comandavano i nobili
gli uomini come Dino
stavano a bottega
quando Firenze
a fine 200
fa questo esperimento
di democrazia
allargata
fin dove si può
perché gli operai
di Dino
non stanno al governo
lui però
che è un imprenditore
che di fronte
ai nobili buondelmonti
si toglie il cappello
invece
si trova fra quelli
che vanno al governo
e spesso si trova
in un organismo
di potere
tenete conto
che il governo
di una città italiana
comunale
è fatto di infinite
commissioni
sotto commissioni
consigli
giunte
fatte di sei uomini
di dodici
di diciotto
di quattro
che durano pochissimo
li cambiano continuamente
al massimo
stanno in carica un anno
ma spesso stanno in carica
anche molto meno
i sei priori
che rappresentano
il vero governo
della città
che prendono
le decisioni
decisive
se così si può dire
i sei priori
cambiano
ogni due mesi
è come se il presidente
del consiglio
e il consiglio
dei ministri
cambiasse
ogni due mesi
perché a loro
sembra l'unico modo
per evitare
che certa gente
prenda troppo potere
e cominci a fare
troppo i suoi affari
dunque queste commissioni
ruotano
un sacco di cittadini
vengono chiamati
a partecipare al governo
e i nobili
non sono mica
tanto contenti
il grande dramma
della Firenze
vista da Dino
compagni
è che abbiamo fatto
questo governo
di popolo
e noi governeremmo
bene la città
nell'interesse collettivo
e invece ci sono
i nobili
con i loro amici
con i loro partiti
con le loro fazioni
che pensano
soltanto all'interesse loro
nessuno pensa
all'interesse collettivo
all'interesse pubblico
e gli scontri
di interesse
sono frequenti
c'è un conflitto
con Arezzo
per l'appunto
Dino
e tanti altri
bravi popolani
sarebbero dell'idea
vabbè ma perché
bisogna fare la guerra
contro Arezzo
ci mettiamo d'accordo
discutiamo
non facciamola
i nobili
la vogliono fare
la guerra
perché a loro conviene
loro la sanno fare
se si fa la guerra
sono stipendi d'oro
per i nobili
e bottino
e vuol dire che loro
conteranno
e se la guerra si vince
chi l'ha vinta
noi i nobili
e quindi i mercanti
stessero un po'
al loro posto
quindi ai nobili conviene
alla fine la guerra
si fa
con tutto che Dino
era il governo
in quel momento
e aveva votato contro
però la guerra
si è fatta
e Dino
qui viene fuori
il mercante
effettivamente
Dino dice
è la guerra
più si consuma
in un di
nella guerra
che in molti anni
non si guadagna
in pace
e lo sa bene
è una delle poche volte
in cui parla di guadagno
nel suo libro
il guadagno
è la sua vita quotidiana
però
lui qui parla di politica
però anche nella politica
c'entra il guadagno
e quando devi decidere
la guerra
al mercante
viene in mente
che la guerra
costa un sacco
di denaro pubblico
se ne risparmierebbe
così tanto
a far la pace
ma i nobili
vogliono la guerra
e si fa la guerra
oltretutto
i nobili
vogliono la guerra
perché appunto
in guerra
contano solo loro
un'altra cosa
che è ovvia
nella testa di Dino
e di quelli come lui
è che la guerra
non gli piace
anche perché loro
non la sanno fare
non la vogliono fare
non gli interessa
in tempo di pace
il mercante
può anche
avere più soldi
del nobile
e essere più bravo
di lui
a amministrare
ma in tempo di guerra
il mercante sta a casa
e il nobile
è quello che comanda
e i mercanti
non si intromettono
nella guerra
dunque la guerra
si fa
e i nobili
sono sempre più
prepotenti
e la caratteristica
della prepotenza
è che non obbidiscono
alle leggi
questa è l'altra cosa
che a Dino
crea
ribrezzo
abbiamo delle buone
leggi a Firenze
se solo fossero
rispettate
la città
sarebbe prospera
ma le leggi
non sono rispettate
perché
un po'
devo dirlo
perché ce n'è per tutti
per colpa dei giudici
i maladetti giudici
dice
Dino
i quali
interpretano la legge
e favoriscono
i loro amici
il loro partito
ecco
ma comunque
se fosse solo quello
ma il problema
è che i nobili
non obbidiscono
alla legge
i nobili
vanno in giro armati
prova un po'
ad arrestarli
e allora la soluzione
è un governo di popolo
ancora più duro
che tenga i nobili
come dire
al loro posto
che li rimetta
che li costringa
a ubbidire
ci hanno provato
una volta
cito sempre Arezzo
perché Dino
cita spesso Arezzo
che in quel momento
è una città toscana
importante
ad Arezzo
dice Dino
i nobili
erano insopportabili
per la loro prepotenza
hanno fatto
un governo
di popolo
hanno chiamato
uno da fuori
che ha comandato
ad Arezzo
e ha messo
i nobili
al loro posto
dice Dino
li costringeva
a ubbidire
alle leggi
che è già
una cosa
inaudita
poi a Firenze
è finita
ad Arezzo
è finita malissimo
i nobili
non ne potevano più
si sono armati
hanno preso
il potere
con la forza
hanno rotto
come dice Dino
il governo
di popolo
il capo
del popolo
lo hanno chiuso
in una cisterna
e lo hanno lasciato
morire di fame
dentro la cisterna
e ad Arezzo
il governo
di popolo
è finito
ma a Firenze
che sono più tosti
i popolani
a Firenze
ci vogliono provare
e fanno
gli ordinamenti
di giustizia
anche questi
li abbiamo sentiti
ricordare a scuola
Giano
della Bella
cosa sono
gli ordinamenti
di giustizia
in due parole
una legge straordinaria
la legge dice
i nobili
non possono avere
nessun incarico
di governo
in tutte le mille
commissioni
sotto commissioni
consigli
che governano
Firenze
se uno è nobile
non ci può stare
secondo
se un nobile
offende
un popolano
se tira fuori
la spada
deve essere punito
non solo lui
ma tutti i suoi parenti
sono tutti tenuti
l'uno per l'altro
e ci deve essere
un organismo
armato
troviamo nel bilancio
i soldi
mettiamo in piedi
un corpo di polizia
al servizio del popolo
che quando
c'è una denuncia
contro un nobile
per violenza
si va lì
si arrestano tutti
si tirano giù
si radono al suolo
le loro case
perché così si faceva
ecco
e così i nobili
staranno al loro posto
e si fa
questo sistema
a partire da quel momento
i sei priori
di Firenze
sono costretti
a stare barricati
dentro il palazzo
della Badia
non c'è ancora
il palazzo comunale
e sul bilancio
di Firenze
si trova da pagare
una guardia speciale
di poliziotti
per proteggerli
perché la vita
di uno dei priori
non vale un soldo
in questo momento
se escono in strada
e incontrano un nobile
ecco
e tuttavia
in questa situazione
di estrema tensione
si riesce
comunque
a far passare
queste leggi
i nobili
esclusi dagli uffici
a un certo punto
Dina dice
sì ma chi sono i nobili
esattamente
perché è facile dirlo
ma
c'è un elenco
facciamolo
fanno l'elenco
ogni famiglia
che ha avuto
un cavaliere
fra i suoi
è da considerare
famiglia nobile
famiglia di magnati
se avete avuto
un cavaliere
non siete dei nostri
perché noi siamo
quella gente pacifica
che vuole lavorare
e far soldi
e che non va in giro
armata
quindi quelli che hanno
dei cavalieri
sono gli altri
noi non li vogliamo
non possono governare
Firenze
i nobili ovviamente
tanto contenti
non sono
lo capite anche voi
i nobili sono fuori
di sé dalla rabbia
tanto più che hanno fatto
la guerra contro Arezzo
l'hanno vinta
hanno vinto la battaglia
di Campaldino
e per tutto ringraziamento
li hanno buttati fuori
dal governo
Dino lo sa
che i nobili
quando si ritrovano
fra loro
lo sa che discorsi fanno
questi popolani
cani
che ci hanno cacciato
dagli uffici
e dagli onori
della nostra città
noi siamo quelli
che demmo
la sconfitta
in Campaldino
e adesso
ci hanno cacciato
dagli uffici
i nobili
sono pronti
a tutto
per tornare al potere
ed è qui
e in questa congiuntura
che Dino
comincia a essere
un uomo politico importante
voi capite che non è
una situazione
proprio facile
da gestire
Dino è un uomo
dei mercanti
è un uomo
delle corporazioni
viene spesso
nominato
fra i priori
come funziona
concretamente
questa politica
che Dino
è chiamato a gestire
cosa vuol dire
come funziona
come succede
è tutto assembleare
è tutto collettivo
perché comunque
i cittadini
si sentono
tutti partecipi
della politica
le decisioni
si prendono
ve lo dicevo
in innumerevoli consigli
dove chiunque
può essere nominato
certi consigli
sono addirittura
sorteggiati
si mettono
i nomi
di tutti i cittadini
dentro un grande sacco
e si tirano sorte
quindi chiunque
può andare al potere
è un esperimento
di democrazia
molto avanzato
siamo a fine 200
e poi tante cose
si discutono
è una cosa
che come dire
un reduce del 68
o del 77
ci si sarebbe trovato
benissimo
nella Firenze
di fine 200
perché a ogni occasione
cosa si fa
si convoca un'assemblea
e nell'assemblea
tutti parlano
e poi
quelli che parlano
più forte
sono quelli che vincono
e tutto si decide così
anche cosa che a noi
sembra assurdo
decidere in quel modo
quando fanno
la famosa guerra
contro Arezzo
di cui vi parlavo
devono prendere
una decisione strategica
fondamentale
cioè noi siamo
i più forti
attacchiamo
ma da che parte
si passa per andare
ad Arezzo
passiamo da Valdarno
o passiamo dal Casentino
è una decisione strategica
importante
ne dipendono
tante altre cose
oggi ci sarebbe
il generale comandante
che decide
invece loro
radunano
una grande assemblea
nel battistero
di San Giovanni
che è il luogo
classico
dove a Firenze
ci si riunisce
perché il palazzo vecchio
non esiste ancora
in quel momento
e quindi nel Duomo
di San Giovanni
tutti i cittadini
più importanti
tutti quelli
che hanno delle poltrone
e ricoprono
degli uffici
tutti i vecchi
cavalieri esperti
tutti i comandanti
militari
tutti lì
e tutti discutono
discutono tutto il giorno
in pubblico
per decidere
se per attaccare Arezzo
si passa dal Casentino
o si passa da Valdarno
e poi per decidere
dopo che tutti
hanno parlato
e hanno detto
il loro parere
come fanno
votano
votano con le fave
bianche e nere
come si vota
in tutti i consigli
ognuno ha la sua
fava bianca
la sua fava nera
poi le depositano
nell'urna
e si vede
e dice Dino
si vinse
di andare
per Casentino
ed era la strada
peggiore
ma comunque
per fortuna
Dio ci ha protetti
e è andato bene
lo stesso
quindi è una democrazia
assembleare
dove le cose
si fanno
con una larghissima
partecipazione
ed è una vita
come dire
anche qui
l'ho già detto ieri
è un mondo semplice
questo
dove ci sono
dei limiti
a quello che si può fare
che oggi
non ci immaginiamo neanche
vi cito un altro esempio
Dino racconta questo
c'è stato un momento
di grave crisi
a Firenze
è arrivato a Firenze
Carlo di Valois
un principe francese
per mettere pace
fra i vari partiti
contrapposti
mandato dal Papa
noi dovevamo
starlo a sentire
per forza
perché è mandato dal Papa
e dal Re di Francia
però
c'era poca fiducia
si aveva paura
che lui volesse favorire
uno dei partiti
contro l'altro
come infatti poi è successo
si è visto
dice Dino
dunque era un momento
bisognava prendere
delle decisioni
rapidamente
che facciamo
di fronte a questo signore
che viene
che verrà a darci degli ordini
bisognava decidere
rapidamente cosa fare
per decidere rapidamente
cosa fare
cosa si fa
si convoca un'assemblea
e tutti possono parlare
c'è un palchetto
con una ringhiera
e gli oratori
a turno salgono
su questo palchetto
e parlano
e Dino dice
noi dovevamo decidere
in fretta
e la gente saliva lì
e parlava
parlava
bandino falconieri
non aveva niente da dire
però è venuto lì
ha tenuto la ringhiera
impacciata
mezza giornata
e si era
dice Dino
nei tempi più bassi
dell'anno
cioè era novembre
voi capite
cosa vuol dire
i giorni sono corti
quando viene buio
si va tutti a casa
non si continua
a star fuori
a discutere
finisce la politica
quando viene buio
si chiude di novembre
alle 5
al pomeriggio
o hai deciso
o è finita
non si sta fuori
quando è buio
queste sono limitazioni
che noi neanche
ci immaginiamo
e invece loro
nella concretezza
della loro vita
li hanno questi problemi
e dunque
in questa politica
in cui Dino
si trova immerso
i soldi
contano molto
è una politica
è un mondo
quello dove i soldi
girano
girano tanto
e contano tanto
senza i soldi
non si fa niente
non si fa la guerra
e non si fa neanche
la politica
quando il comune
ha bisogno di soldi
i cittadini ricchi
i grossi finanzieri
anticipano i soldi
al comune
e bisogna anche
ringraziarli
poi è chiaro
che quando hai anticipato
i soldi al comune
poi
intanto aspetti
la restituzione
ma in attesa
della restituzione
ci sono tanti modi
per farsi ricompensare
quindi cittadini ricchi
i grandi banchieri
prestano volentieri
i soldi al governo
ecco
i soldi contano
contano in politica
estra
si fa tutto
con i soldi
è raro
trovare qualcuno
come il cardinale
Matteo d'Acquasparta
che viene mandato
a Firenze
a un certo punto
dal Papa
come al solito
perché voi dovete sapere
che Firenze
è una grande alleata
del Papa
e il Papa
è leggermente sconfortato
di vedere che a Firenze
non fanno altro
che scannarsi
fra parti
fra partiti
e che la città
è continuamente divisa
da guerre civili
da scontri
il Papa
vorrebbe mettere pace
e loro hanno una gran paura
che arrivi qualcuno
dal Papa
con degli ordini
perché gli secca
che vengano i cardinali
a dargli degli ordini
però
a un certo punto
arriva il cardinale
Matteo d'Acquasparta
e cerca di mettere pace
e a molta gente
questa cosa
da fastidio
e finalmente
si trova uno
dice Dino
uno di poco senno
che gli tira
una freccia
con la balestra
alla finestra
di casa
la freccia
si pianta
dentro l'impannata
della finestra
non succede niente
però il cardinale
ci rimane piuttosto male
sta per andarsene
gettando l'interdetto
su Firenze
allora bisogna calmarlo
bisogna pacificarlo
che si fa per pacificare
il cardinale
gli mandiamo dei soldi
il governo decide
vanno a vedere la legge
quanti soldi
si possono stanziare
senza dover fare
una votazione
a voto palese
perché se bisogna fare
una votazione
a voto palese
non ne usciamo più
a voto segreto
si possono mandare
fino a 2000 fiorini
e quindi
va bene
al cardinale
d'Acquasparta
mandiamo 2000 fiorini
e Dino e gli altri
glieli portano
anzi Dino in persona
dice glieli porta
in una coppa d'argento
gli porta i 2000 fiorini
nuovi
dice appena
coniati
e gli dice al cardinale
Messere
guardate sono pochi
lo so
2000 fiorini
sono una somma colossale
ma comunque
sono pochi
ma di più
non si può spendere
senza fare il voto palese
quindi abbiate pazienza
e il cardinale
rispose
che li aveva cari
e molto li guardò
e non li volle
ma di questi
ce ne sono pochissimi
appunto
che i soldi
non li prendono
i soldi normalmente
li prendono tutti
e la politica
in città
si fa per questo
il quadro
che dà Dino
della politica
in cui lui
si è trovato a operare
è un quadro
sconvolgente
dove dell'interesse pubblico
non interessa niente
a nessuno
dove tutti
sono in politica
per fare gli interessi
loro
e dei loro parenti
e del loro partito
nell'ordine
e quelle sono
le uniche cose
che importano
e dunque
lui dice
c'è continuamente
la gara
d'uffici
gli uffici
sono le poltrone
capite
sono le innumerevoli
poltrone
che ti permettono
per due mesi
magari soltanto
di prendere
delle decisioni importanti
per queste poltrone
ci si scanna
e si fa di tutto
poi una volta
che l'hai ottenuta
la poltrona
e sai che ce l'hai
solo per due mesi
e quindi devi sbrigarti
anche a farla fruttare
a quel punto
succede di tutto
si compra e si vende
tutto
si comprano e si vendono
gli appalti
i processi
poi dice Dino
è chiaro che in questo modo
decisioni non se ne prendono mai
questo devo dire
fa venire un brivido
nella nostra Italia di oggi
quando si legge questo
Dino dice
ogni cosa decisa
un giorno
viene disfatta
il giorno dopo
e lo cito ancora
il male
per legge
non si punisce
come il malfattore
ha degli amici
e può moneta
spendere
così è liberato
dal maleficio fatto
in questa situazione
appunto
la posta in gioco
è grossa
stare al governo
vuol dire
non aver problemi con la giustizia
che i tuoi processi
vengono insabbiati
e vuol dire
che sei tu
che metti le mani
nelle tasche dei cittadini
per usare ancora
un linguaggio
insomma
attualizzante
perché il governo
tassa
e tassa per
però
non voglio
come dire
non voglio strappare
degli applausi
fin troppo facili
io sto parlando
della Firenze
di fine del 200
a Firenze
alla fine del 200
i grandi problemi
quali sono?
è la ripartizione
delle imposte
il denaro pubblico
c'è il tesoro
del comune
e quelli che sono
al potere
avrebbero
giurano
di salvaguardare
il tesoro
del comune
e invece
dice Dino
trovavano modo
come meglio
il potessero rubare
e tiravano fuori
i soldi
dal tesoro
dice sotto pretesto
di ricompensare
persone che avevano
servito il comune
fino a 2000
Fiorini
si capisce
non c'è bisogno di votare
si dà
e i soldi
vanno fuori
ci sono casi
scandalosi
c'è un caso
in particolare
che Dino nota
perché veramente
la gente
non ne poteva più
è morto
un grossissimo
capopartito
Messer Rosso
della Tosa
uno degli uomini
più ricchi e influenti
di Firenze
il comune
ha deciso
di ricompensare
la sua famiglia
per i grandi servigi
resi da questo
capopartito
ha armato cavalieri
a spese del comune
i figli
di Messer Rosso
della Tosa
ora voi dovete sapere
che armare uno cavaliere
è una cosa costosissima
perché richiede
grandi festeggiamenti
banchetti pubblici
regali
acquisto di cavalli
di armature
è una spesa enorme
è anche per quello
che i cavalieri
sono prestigiosi
perché sono pochi
ci vogliono tanti soldi
per essere cavaliere
ecco
il comune decide
che col denaro pubblico
si armano cavalieri
e si coprono di regali
i due figli
di questo ricchissimo
capopartito
e la gente
e la gente mormora
ma non può farci niente
si accontenta
di prenderli in giro
la gente dice
qualcuno ha fatto il conto
che tutti i soldi spesi
per armare cavalieri
questi due figli di papà
più o meno equivalevano
alle tasse pagate
dalle povere operaie
che lavorano nei filatoi
e che fanno la fame
e che si tolgono il pane di bocca
per pagare le tasse
e le operaie del filatoio
per cui dice
li chiamavano
i cavalieri del filatoio
e va bene però
come dire
magra consolazione
tutto sommato
perché chi è al governo
con i soldi pubblici
fa quello che vuole
e ogni tanto
arriva qualcuno
che dice
ma non è possibile
dove finiscono i soldi
bisogna vedere
bisogna fare i conti
ma Dino sa benissimo
che quando arriva qualcuno
a dire queste cose
è perché
la sua fazione
in quel momento
non è al governo
e vuole buttare giù
gli altri
e quindi la fazione
che non è al governo
è sempre pronta
a chiamare i cittadini
in piazza
e dire
ma i soldi dove sono finiti
non è possibile
che per la guerra
contro Arezzo
se ne sono spesi così tanti
chi è che se li è messi
in tasca
però Dino
ci crede poco
che questa classe politica
fatta di grandi nobili
sia in grado
realmente
di moralizzare
la vita pubblica
lui si trova
al governo
più volte
e il suo ideale
è di cercare
di pacificare
le parti
lo dice lui
sia chiaro
intendiamoci
dice lui
che il suo ideale
è di fare
l'interesse comune
non fare
fare in modo
che nessun partito
prevalga
mettere fine
alle ruberie
lui si trova
al governo
ma è stritolato
da queste forze
contrapposte
notate che
come vi dicevo
il governo
dei sei priori
dura due mesi
dopo due mesi
si sa che vanno via
se ne nominano altri sei
bene
in certi momenti
l'opposizione
scende in piazza
e minaccia
cataclismi
perché vuole
le dimissioni
dei priori
non basta che fra due mesi
si dovranno dimettere
comunque
richiedere le dimissioni
del governo
in carica
è una cosa
che in certi momenti
si fa con estrema
insistenza
e petulanza
dicendo questo governo
non è neutrale
vogliamo un governo
veramente neutrale
Dino
a un certo punto
si trova costretto
a cedere
lui sarebbe
dei priori
e al governo
avrebbe ancora
un po' di settimane
in carica
ma sono talmente
forti le pressioni
delle grandi fazioni
dei partiti
che vogliono
che si dimettano
che loro dicono
va bene
sarebbe illegale
ma noi
va bene
ci dimettiamo
convochiamo
una riunione
di tutti i capi partito
e nominiamo
un nuovo governo
convocano
questa riunione
e Dino
è molto fiero
dice io
ci sono due partiti
contrapposti principali
i guelfi bianchi
e i guelfi neri
che si scannano
in piazza
facciamo questo nuovo governo
lo facciamo paritario
dice Dino
perché è fondamentale
io non voglio fare
delle porcherie
facciamo un governo
veramente paritario
i priori sono sei
tre bianchi
e tre neri
poi ci sarebbe
una settima carica
di governo
il gonfaloniere
di giustizia
che è quello
che comanda
la polizia
e quando
secondo gli ordinamenti
di giustizia
un nobile
commette un delitto
deve farlo arrestare
andare a far spianare
le sue case
e così via
ecco
il settimo
il gonfaloniere
di giustizia
dice Dino
non si poteva dividere
perciò come fanno
non potendolo dividere
vogliono fare un governo
assolutamente paritario
che tutti i partiti
siano soddisfatti
come si fa
con il settimo
dice Dino
beh
abbiamo scelto uno
che valeva così poco
che non poteva fare paura
a nessuno
come vedete
il manuale Cencelli
non l'ha inventato nessuno
loro hanno esattamente
questa stessa preoccupazione
di ripartizione
ebbene
dice Dino
lì mentre eravamo
a discutere
stavamo facendo
il nuovo governo
con tre da una parte
tre dall'altra
equilibrato
è arrivato
uno dei capi partito
dei neri
lui fa nomi
e cognomi
mi ha preso da parte
e mi ha detto
ma senti Dino
ma non si potrebbe fare
che date più posti a noi
e di meno a quegli altri
e Dino
di fronte a questa cosa
è indignato
perché voi capite
che questa politica
io la sto raccontando
come una politica
ma poi la parte
che si trova in minoranza
rischia che un bel giorno
gli fanno la pelle
fisicamente
perché quello è
come dire
lo sbocco poi
delle rivalità
Dino ha questa idea
che lui sta facendo
finalmente un governo
insomma
equilibrato
dove ci sono
la destra e la sinistra
i bianchi e i neri
in parti uguali
e poi arriva uno
a dirgli
ma senti dai più posti
a noi invece
lui dice
io la parte del Giuda
non la voglio fare
e io gli risposi
che innanzi che io
facessi tanto tradimento
darei i miei figliuoli
a mangiare i cani
dopodiché
per questa volta
tiene duro
e riesce a resistere
e questo governo
così equilibrato
fatto in parti uguali
dove i due partiti avversi
sono rappresentati
alla pari
provate a indovinare
se dura lungo o no
non dura niente
immediatamente
ricade
e si ricomincia
dunque Dino
si trova a fare politica
in un momento
in cui la politica
di Firenze
è in mano
a capi partito
arrabbiati
disposti a usare
la violenza
e che
secondo lui
non hanno nessuna idea
di cos'è l'interesse pubblico
vogliono solo occuparsi
di farlo il potere
e lui rappresenta
se stesso
va a sapere poi
noi abbiamo la sua voce
però lui
di questi partiti
non fa parte
lui è un uomo modesto
è un piccolo imprenditore
è finito al governo
perché il sistema è quello
lui
il suo ideale
è la concordia
e lui ci sta male
che i cittadini
non la capiscono
questa cosa
che staremmo tutti bene
se ci fosse
la concordia
in città
se fossimo tutti
veramente
patriottici
i cittadini
di questa nostra
meravigliosa città
sarebbe così ricca
Firenze
e invece
andiamo in rovina
per questo
quando lui fa dei discorsi
fa questi discorsi
appunto
ispirati a questa idea
ma perché litigate
perché volete
confondere
disfare
una così buona città
contro chi
volete combattere
contro i vostri fratelli
lui fa questi discorsi
patetici
certe volte
li commuove
in apparenza
c'è una situazione
in cui veramente
la città
sta per esplodere
la guerra civile
lui convoca
per l'ennesima volta
l'avete capito
un'assemblea
in battistero
e in battistero
fa questo grande discorso
dove dice
ma siamo tutti fratelli
siete stati
tutti battezzati
qui
in questo
fonte battesimale
perché a quell'epoca
si battezzava
soltanto lì
in cattedrale
quindi ogni fiorentino
era passato di lì
da quel fonte
battesimale
di San Giovanni
e lui fa questo discorso
strappa lacrime
questo appello
come dire
alle emozioni
e dice
poi piangevano
io gli ho detto
giuriamo
di essere tutti uniti
di non fare più
del male
alla nostra città
piangevano
hanno giurato tutti
quelli che piangevano
di più
sono quelli
che appena usciti
hanno ricominciato
a tramare
per distruggere tutto
e un'altra cosa
che dice Dino
è
ma
sarebbe stato
ragionevole
far la pace
perché queste lotte
di fazione
portano il disastro
a tutti
la ragione
ci dice
che dovremmo
andare d'accordo
ed è di nuovo
questo appello
alla ragione
che per la gente
di quell'epoca
era una cosa fondamentale
loro hanno sempre
in bocca
la ragione
non è un'epoca
come dire
oscura da questo punto
di vista
il medioevo
per loro la ragione
è un ideale straordinario
perché la ragione
l'ha data Dio
secondo loro
naturalmente
però loro
l'ideale
di una gestione
razionale
delle cose
loro ce l'hanno in testa
poi invece gli uomini
non sono capaci
di essere razionali
e di essere ragionevoli
e dunque la città
sprofonda nel caos
nonostante tutti gli sforzi
della brava gente
come Dino
che vorrebbe riportare
la politica cittadina
all'equilibrio
la città sprofonda
nel caos
e tra le due
grandi fazioni
ci abbiamo anche a concludere
naturalmente
vista l'ora
tra le due grandi fazioni
i guelfi bianchi
e i guelfi neri
si comincia anche
a capire
chi vincerà
e chi vincerà
purtroppo
dice Dino
si capisce
perché alla testa
dei guelfi bianchi
ci sono i cerchi
grande famiglia
che però
sono gente nuova
sono mercanti
che hanno fatto i soldi
erano gente come me
come Dino
hanno fatto i soldi
adesso sono cavalieri
hanno le armi
i cavalli
però nel cuore
nell'anima
sono sempre mercanti
e invece dall'altra parte
alla testa dei neri
ci sono dei baroni
ci sono i donati
che sono dei grandi nobili
antichi
abituati a far la guerra
e vedendo questo
la gente che capisce
come va il mondo
dice Dino
ha cominciato
a un certo punto
a dire
eh
qui non c'è partita
qui da una parte
abbiamo i cerchi
e sono mercatanti
e naturalmente
sono vili
e i loro nemici
sono maestri di guerra
e crudeli uomini
se un partito
è guidato da mercanti
e l'altro partito
è guidato da nobili
cavalieri
non c'è
non c'è partita appunto
perché i mercanti
cercheranno sempre
il compromesso
la pacificazione
non hanno voglia
di dire
sai che c'è
tiriamo fuori le spade
e vediamo
chi è più uomo
e invece ai nobili
vi è naturale
ragionare così
i nobili
piuttosto che accettare
il compromesso
la pacificazione
tirano fuori le spade
e Dino lo ammette
noi stessi
io e gli altri mercanti
che eravamo al governo
in quel momento
lui scrive anni dopo
quando ormai è andata
a finire malissimo
noi che eravamo al governo
in quel momento
siamo stati deboli
siamo stati vili
non abbiamo capito
che non era più
il momento di mediare
noi abbiamo cercato
di mediare
abbiamo cercato
di convocare assemblee
di convocare riunioni
di mettere insieme tutti
di pacificarli
e abbiamo perso
il momento giusto
perché non bisognava
fare quello
non era quello
il momento
non bisognava
trattare di pace
bisognava
dice Dino
arrotare i ferri
cioè affilare
le spade
e noi che eravamo
mercanti
quello non l'abbiamo capito
ecco
in questa politica
della Firenze
medievale
voi vi sarete accorti
che finora
è mancata completamente
una cosa
io non ho mai parlato
neanche lontanamente
della dimensione religiosa
noi siamo abituati
a pensare
agli uomini del medioevo
e abbiamo ragione
come una società
profondamente religiosa
dove la fede cristiana
conta e conta molto
è vero
conta molto
per l'interiorità
di ciascuno
ma in questa politica
dei comuni italiani
la religione
non conta niente
è una politica
talmente feroce
talmente spietata
dove l'unica posta
è il potere
che la religione
non conta niente
chi la religione
dentro di sé
la sente
vede la contraddizione
Dino
Dino a un certo punto
li ha fatti giurare
ha fatto giurare
tutti i cittadini
più importanti
tutti i capi partito
in San Giovanni
che avrebbero fatto
la pace
anni dopo
dice Dino
io continuo a pensarci
a questa cosa
che ho fatto
e ho paura
e sono pentito
di averlo fatto
perché quelli
si sono dannati tutti
hanno tutti giurato
e non ce n'è uno
che l'abbia mantenuto
questo giuramento
ma sono io
che li ho fatti giurare
non avrei dovuto farlo
la dimensione religiosa
è l'estrema risorsa
di chi in politica
ormai sente
che sta perdendo
e non ce la fa più
allora ricorre a quello
Dino a un certo punto
dice abbiamo fatto
anche questo
sempre il governo lui
sempre i partiti
armati contro l'uno
contro l'altro
la città che sta per
sprofondare nella guerra civile
Dino dice
è arrivato un frate
un santo frate
un uomo religioso
ben conosciuto
ci ha detto
perché non fate una processione
una grande processione
in città
per invocare
la protezione di Dio
e perché tutti i cittadini
nella processione
possano ritrovare
la loro unità
e dice Dino
sì l'abbiamo fatta
abbiamo fatta la processione
lui ci credeva
in quel momento
ma non ci crede
già quasi più nessuno
in realtà in città
tant'è vero
che Dino dice
abbiamo fatto la processione
e molti ci schernirono
dicendo che meglio era
arrotare i ferri
appunto
di nuovo
era meglio affilare le spade
e non fare la processione
la religione
della politica
è già fuori
non c'è niente da fare
in quella politica
c'è soltanto
il potere
da prendere
a raffare
a tutti i costi
in tutti i modi
e la religione
rimane
e come rimane
rimane come la consolazione
di quelli che hanno perso
alla fine
Dino perde
perché a un certo punto
i capi partito
violenti
prendono il potere
ed è finita
con i piccoli mercanti
chiamati al governo
che tornino
alle loro imprese
alle loro aziende
Dino rimane ancora
tanti anni a Firenze
non è coinvolto
nelle parti
lo lasciano stare
mentre quelli
della parte bianca
che perde
vengono esiliati
in massa da Firenze
è il momento
in cui anche Dante Alighieri
viene esiliato da Firenze
perché stava col partito
che ha perso
Dino no
è uno che non conta
è stato al governo
quando i mercanti
credevano di comandare loro
ma adesso è finita
ci sono di nuovo
i nobili cavalieri
che comandano
intendiamoci
d'accordo
con i mercanti più ricchi
perché i mercanti più ricchi
e i finanzieri grossi
hanno capito presto
che a loro in realtà
conveniva mettersi
con i nobili
e sposare le loro figlie
e partecipare
ai loro tornei
e costruirsi
dei bei palazzi
delle torri
e comprare i cavalli
e le armi
e stare con i nobili
e i piccoli imprenditori
e i bottegai
e gli artigiani
sì
possono restare in città
ma basta con la politica
con la politica importante
hanno chiuso
quel
Dino ha chiuso
vivrà ancora molti anni
gestendo la sua compagnia
di import export
e aspettando di vedere
se Dio punisce
tutti questi malvagi
che hanno fatto
hanno portato la città
alla rovina
secondo lui
aspetta
perché la giustizia di Dio
è lenta
aspetta
a un certo punto
gli sembra che però
le cose si stiano mettendo bene
perché scende in Italia
l'imperatore Enrico VII
e l'imperatore Enrico VII
scende in Italia
e sembra che sia arrivato
il Castigamatti
che riporterà l'ordine
che porterà la pace
e Dino è entusiasta
ci crede
voi capite
che razza di rinuncia è
la città da sola
non si può governare
non esiste
deve venire qualcuno da fuori
più grosso e più forte di noi
che ci comandi
e allora forse
sapremo stare in pace
e saremo governati bene
arriva l'imperatore
dice Dino
e sta venendo
lui lo aspetta
sta scendendo in Italia
mettendo pace
come fosse uno angelo di Dio
perché in ogni città che tocca
pacifica i partiti
fa rientrare gli esiliati
questa è la grande speranza
quando Dino scrive
sta ancora aspettando
che l'imperatore arrivi
non succederà niente
naturalmente
neanche stavolta
l'imperatore non farà niente
Dino non lo sa ancora
e poi sta a guardare
Dino
cosa succede
ai grandi capi partito
a quelli che erano
come dire
alla guida delle fazioni
quando hanno distrutto
il governo di popolo
e hanno riportato
come dire
l'affermazione violenta
più brutale
al potere della città
e i grandi capi partito
è
Dino è fortunato
vive a lungo
prima o poi muoiono
e vedendoli morire
uno dopo l'altro
Dino si dice
beh dopo tutto
una giustizia c'è
in questo mondo
ecco
noi in politica
abbiamo perso
ci hanno buttati fuori
dal potere
si sono presi
tutto loro
però Dio
è là
e vede
e uno dopo l'altro
li va a prendere
e c'è quello
che è inciampato
mentre andava per strada
e si è rotto il ginocchio
e i chirurghi
l'hanno torturato
per un mese
e poi gli è venuta
la cancrene
ed è crepato
e uno dopo l'altro
muoiono
e Dino sta a vedere
e si dice
sì
dopo tutto
la giustizia di Dio
c'è
e arriva
ecco
quelli erano uomini
del medioevo
e avevano questa speranza
di fronte alla politica
del loro tempo
ma noi non siamo qui
per fare dei paralleli
con l'oggi
ero qui per raccontarvi
come vedeva il mondo
un mercante fiorentino
grazie